[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis for our kickoff show for the 2019
st. Louis norm Congress my name is Ben
Simon and I'm joined by a man making his
live commentary debut our grand master
in residence Alexander Linderman Alex
it's good to be working with you man
thank you as a show likewise yeah so the
purpose of this event is twofold of
course we're looking for winners we're
looking for winners of two different
sections we have a grandmaster norm
section and an IM norm section whoever
comes in first they're the champ they
leave with the money hooray
but also there's a another facet of this
event and it is something called the
norm and I want to bring up right now
what exactly is a norm
it's complicated if you're not from the
chess realm and sometimes even if you're
from the chess world you don't know what
a norm is so here is what you have what
enormous it is an achievement it is a
notch in your black belt if you get
three of them you are on your way to
getting a chess title be it
international master or the big one the
Grandmaster so to earn a norm a player
must score quantifiably well they must
get a certain score in a tournament
where at least three other players
already hold the title being sought so
we will show you the fields coming up
here soon we have three grandmasters in
the GM norm field where players who are
not grandmasters are trying to attain
that title and then we have three
international masters in the second
section and then the rest of the players
are trying to get that title that's what
that means the average rating of all the
players in the event must be above a
minimum rating it's 2380 the average for
Grandmaster norms hey we hit that 24:52
is the average for our Grandmaster norm
section and at least for national
federations are going to be represented
we have those actually six in our
Grandmaster and arm section five in our
international master norm section now to
be fair in larger events you do need
more than four Federation's for nations
to be represented but we meet the
qualifications here Alex
this is a really exciting event
and you've made it okay you're the
Grandmaster what can you tell us about
the norms
yeah well it's obviously very
challenging you have to play well
throughout the whole tournament
you basically have to score at least for
example if you're gonna become a if you
want to get a grandmaster Dorn right you
need to achieve at least a 2600 to feed
a rating performance and in order to
become a Grandmaster your rating
requirement is 2500 fidei so basically
even if you're already Grandmaster
strength 2500 you still have to perform
over a hundred points above your absol
level and if you're 2450 player then you
have to score 150 points above your
level so you really have to have a very
good tournament you have to over perform
you have to be either in very good form
sometimes you also need some lucky
breaks or a couple of critical moments
sometimes you might need both but you
know it's not a secret that you have to
play very well in that tournament and
play some very good chess and to get
that what we call the tournament
performance rating that is if you only
play this one tournament based on this
one tournament
what is your rating at the end of it
that's what the tournament performance
rating is in a nutshell to get that TPR
you do have to get X amount of points in
this nine round event so for most
players that is six and a half and to
get like the GM norm or the iron on but
there's other norms but possibilities on
the line possibly as well in this event
and also all the players have different
backgrounds some players have met all of
the norm requirements but they still
have to make the Radian threshold we
were talking about one of the players
just in wing who has he's clinched
everything I think my fault yeah we'll
have to check on that later on tonight
but let's see the players in this event
starting with our masters division our
Grandmaster group now you'll see at
there that at the top JJ a Lima Ronde
he's the highest rated player followed
by a Jackson and Lea but we were talking
like maybe we should focus more on the
players who
aren't most likely to win because that's
what this event is all about it's about
the underdog story Alex yeah that's
absolutely true and in such an even
field where you know the players are all
around to the similar similar in
strength it's very much a crap show who
will actually win the tournament but I
think everybody in this term has a
reasonable chance of getting a norm as
long as they you know play very good
chess in the tournament so for Brandon
Jacobson Casa Corley Bryan Escalante
Justin Wang Andrew Hong Joel Bernama and
Tata of Abraham Ian the goal is six and
a half points six and a half out of nine
that is not going to be easy but there's
a good reason you get six and a half out
of nine at the end of this thing and you
get a grandmaster norm also on the line
in this field a couple of international
master norms possible for Justin Wang
who may or may not need it yeah and for
Tata of Abraham Ian four and a half
points out of the nine we'll get you one
of your three international master
Norman requirements well can you tell us
about the players in this field who are
you familiar with Alex I'm familiar with
all the players in this tournament I've
blades at least six out of ten here and
I've met most of them I've played
Brendan Jacobsen quite a lot as well as
Casa Corley because they're both from
New York so I've played them numerous
times at the Marshall chess club so I'm
very familiar with their playing styles
I think they're both very talented
creative players who you know I had a
good event they easily can you know get
that six and a half on a good day they
can play like a very strong guy masters
so you know there are definitely very
dangerous and even let's say when they
were lower rated they've gotten like for
example Casa Corley got a draw got two
draws off of me with black when he was
less than 2,300 fidei and was winning in
both games actually at some point and
Brandon also we played two long games
you know we it was two draws and that
was when a couple of years ago when he
was around 2300 feet
as well so they're definitely very much
capable players and and now they're even
stronger even more experienced I know
Brandon lately has been on a tear like
winning tournaments after tournaments
and I mean I see great a great future
for him he's only 15 or 16 years old
very young so I easily see him as a
what's a potential future superstar like
strong guy master maybe even you know
better than me someday
so we'll see good and you're one of the
best in the u.s. so that's saying
something well that's I mean not quite
one of the best but you know I'm hopeful
l I still have room to improve but thank
you for your kind words you're one of
the best okay look we have those elite
guys who just moved in but come on all
right let's take a look at our second
group the International master norm
event this we have ten players here
including a player from the landlocked
Burundi and Africa representing Burundi
Ezra chambers so in this event the
players are going for the second most
valuable title in chess the
International master title and we have
Keaton Kyra Eric Rosen and Luis Torres
as our gatekeepers but they're not the
highest rated by feeder rating we have
Olivia Olivia
chiku rata and I'm gonna check on that
pronunciation in a couple hours guys
Gauri Shankar above them and then down
in the middle Erin Grubb in ski we're
very familiar with him the national
master who plays in many of our events
here at the st. Louis chess club Erin
Jacobson who is actually Brandon's older
brother by four years Peter G inaros of
the Charlotte chess Center chess
celebrity in his own right and and we
mentioned Ezra and then at the bottom
Rochelle woo no stranger to st. Louis
competition as well she's actually in
the opening montage at the top of the
show she played in last year's norm
congress and in this event to get
internet international master norm the
requirement is six and a half points but
for Rachelle since she's the lowest
rated she'll be having the toughest
schedule she
at six points and also on the line woman
Grandmaster title for Rochelle if she
gets six point she will also get a wgm
norm as well so your familiarity with
this field Alex I think only as her
chamber so I might not I might I'm not a
hundred percent sure if I'm familiar
with him but besides that I'm familiar
with all of them and I'm actually I've
actually played the first eight players
in tournaments before some blitz some
you know longer games but I've
definitely even played all of them and
again they're all tough players I mean
gogo Yuri
beat me once when I was already a
grandmaster you know and then a lot of
them got drawers off oh yeah Aaron
grubens key recently beat me here in st.
Louis in a decisive game in a small
tournament
Oliver chick errata drew me with block
in a tournament so they're all you know
again very capable players and you know
all of them have a chance realistically
to get the norm if they play very good
chest and you might be sitting at home
or your office or wherever you are
thinking where the game show us the
games well the games will be live for
you tonight at us chess champs comm
check it out at 5:00 p.m. Central Time
the games will be available in their dgt
format but we will be on the air every
day at 2:00 p.m. to call the action mid
round for the most exciting parts and
analysis we will have interviews with
the players as they win their games and
come into the studio but that's why we
call this a kickoff show this is the
pregame okay we're going to be on for
about twenty to thirty minutes here just
to give you the lowdown on what's
happening but tonight at 5:00 p.m. US
chess champs calm you can watch the
games and all along the way be sure to
join us on social media with hashtag
norm Congress we don't have to say st.
Louis because norm Congress you know
what it's about
hashtag norm Congress and the YouTube
chat will be open as well let's take a
look at the tournament format it's
pretty easy to understand its classical
chess too
play around Robbins we just saw the
fields the time control is 90 minutes
with a 30-second increment from move
number one there is no second time
control the players have to keep
notation for the entire time because of
the increment and we're gonna get some
good fighting chess out of this because
of the increment you get time to think
what do you think of this time control
Alex oh I think it's a very good time
control I mean normally and let's say in
a lot of Chester events we use a 10
second delay and you know that here we
use increment but some more standard
feed a time control I think there are
pluses and minuses for both I think the
main difference between the increment
time control and in too late time
control is obviously if you have
increment you who you can build up time
which means let's say if you're pressing
in a slightly better endgame you have a
more of a chance to grind that endgame
out if you're playing with the delay
because opponent can't play easy moves
in game time on the clock and you can
really torture them for a long time but
with the increment you have to really
create more serious problems more
practical problems to let's say outplay
the opponent but you know also 30
seconds is quite a lot of time to play a
simple position but still you know
Lincoln could be misleading because if
let's say you're you know in a very
complicated position 30 seconds per move
especially with nerves in a won't quite
be enough to figure out let's say very
very complicated positions so either way
if it's very complicated than increment
or delay it's close to the same but if
it's a technical position then of course
the difference between the delay
increment and increment is huge you know
tonight 30 minutes before the start of
the round executive director of the
Chess Club International arbiter Tony
rich will be having a players meeting
with all the competitors and it's very
important that they listen closely
because if you think there's a second
time control you might be in a little
bit of trouble at move number 40 no
second time control the most you're
gonna get us 30 seconds added on per
move oh yeah there's one more thing I
wanted to add though it is very
important rule that to those of you who
are maybe less experienced players you
have to write down every single move if
you're playing with the
30 second increment because 30 seconds
is more than enough time to record your
moves so even if you're down you always
have at least 30 seconds on your clock
so that's why you have to always write
down your moves at all times whereas if
you're playing with delays then of
course if you're below five minutes you
can stop recording moves analyst unless
you want to let's say try to claim a
threefold repetition in that case you
have to either have an arbiter there or
you have to keep writing down moves but
yeah luckily when it's 30 seconds per
move and all the moves are written down
it's much easier for all these claims to
be done there is second I'm excuse me
threefold repetition 50 move roll and so
on and so forth these claims very well
everybody in the chat there are
wondering what is happening there's no
games
oh gosh everybody freaked out yeah like
I said 5:00 p.m. tonight u.s. chess
champs calm it's just a kickoff show
guys stop freaking out let's take a look
at the tournament schedule so you know
there's no question about it when you'll
be able to see the games as they're
happening tonight 5:00 p.m. round one
and then tomorrow we have we have a
typical schedule where it's very
atypical actually two rounds per day and
then we finish off with the final two
rounds they get their own days the fee
day requirements say that the event to
be a norm tournament has to be at least
five days long and we've met all of the
qualifications that were necessary so
some of these days tomorrow Saturday
Sunday they're gonna be pretty intensive
well there's actually one thing I want
to add doing in it so as far as I know
Reese and that's a rule kind of came
into place recently that as far as I
remember either one or two of your norms
have to be six-day events it can't be
that every single one of your norms is
only a five-day event so that's why in
st. Louis instead of just having let's
say one game than two - two - we have
let's say one game per day two games per
day two games per day two games per day
but then one game per day one game per
day
so that the event lasts 66 days so
that's actually also very important
faculty I think this stuff is
complicated a little bit yeah but I want
to go back to the schedule here because
something important that you guys should
know even though we have this 11 a.m. 5
p.m.
those are the two times you need to
remember through all this tournament we
are on the air at 2 p.m. every day
central time so 2 p.m. will get you the
best of rounds 2 4 6 and 8 and if
anything really important happens in the
other rounds we'll take a look round 9
we're gonna be on until the end of that
so we're gonna be on starting at 2 will
be on we'll talk to the champions of the
field any norm earners so 2 p.m. is what
you need to remember to watch our
wonderful broadcast with the world's
greatest be team but you can see the
games as they're happening at us chess
champs calm on those fabulous chests 24
digital boards ok let's take a look at
the pairings for this evening if we have
them the grandmaster norm section I
think the game that sticks out well
let's go over them individually first JJ
Alomar on day vs. Casa Corley Justin
Wang vs. Danish Boris Jackson Bulli AK
vs. Brandon Jacobson Bryan Escalante vs.
Andrew Hong and Joel bernama vs. top tip
abraham me and one of my tooth they're
two of my favorite chess players in the
entire in the entire chest world if I
can be a little bit biased for a second
but that game in the middle
Jack's Jim Bowie AK and Brandon Jacobson
that's got to be our key matchup because
that's seed number two versus seed
number three does anything pop out at
you tonight as we look forward to round
one games Oh
Mattia because I think that they're all
as I said evenly matched and they're all
you know having a chance and they're all
pretty close in rating but yeah I would
agree with you I think you've gained
Stamboul against Brendan Jacobsen is
very important because if Brandon can
somehow start off well and win the game
with black especially then
can really set a tone and when your
young player trying to get a norm it's
very important to start off well to
really continue the momentum and gain
the confidence but also JJ Lehrer
morontia against Kasich orally because
Kasich orally is a player who is capable
of beating anyone on a given day and
Alomar on D is also a sharp dynamic
glare you know he's someone who plays
and gives other people a chance to play
so that should also be a quite an
interesting game I think but I think you
know any of these games can obviously
become very interesting yeah there's
there's some new names here that we have
not talked to in this in this event
before or the classics I think the norm
Congress in the class they kind of go
hand in hand the seasonal classics I'm
talking about but even though the
objective here is a little bit different
but my objective is to see all these new
players that are coming to the st. Louis
I think it's really fabulous people like
Bryan Escalante and Casa Corley Bryan
Escalante I believe sleight is at the
Webster University yeah right now
exactly and the local colleges are
bringing in so many great players it's
it's just a hotbed yeah definitely late
yeah it's it's great for that I've seen
that you know there are so many colleges
especially in Dallas and st. Louis for
do you know having so many very strong
players even strong GM's you know a
little bit about that I'd say sure let's
take a look at our B group the
International master norm section Luis
Torres versus Keaton Kiera Erin Griffin
ski versus Edgar chambers Peter Gian a
dose versus Gauri Shankar oliviers chiku
rata versus Rochelle Wu and Eric Rosen
versus Erin Jacobson any games stick out
to you in this field I this is very even
as well I think the game that stands out
a little bit as Oliver chick or odds
against Rochelle Wu because it's
interesting to see Rochelle is I think a
very capable of player because she
recently I've seen her compete at the
World Team Championship I was also there
and she played some very great
enterprising chess winning against some
very higher high rated
so she can get off and if she can you
know start off strongly against the top
seed in the tournament you know with
luck that can really be a very big boost
to our chances in it to do very well in
the event and also watch out for Aaron
Reubens Keegan's as her chambers because
Aaron Grubb in ski is someone I feel
heartbroken for because he games he's
actually has all his I am norms and he
came extremely close to reaching his
2400 feet high rating but then all he
needed to do is just win like at some
point one game against the Laura
lower-rated and he lost it and now he's
back to 23:38 so I'm really also rooting
for him to have a good tournament so get
back and closer to 2400 for him it's
more about just playing good chess and
getting back on track rather than
getting that extra norm and asked Tony
rich just to clarify yesterday about
when you hit the rating threshold what
do you how long do you need to stay
there and he said hey if you're there
for one game and you're live rating hits
that magical number you're in that's the
point yeah that's the whole point and
for him he just came very close he hit
maybe like 2390 or something but then
just couldn't get that one last win or
something and it's just it's always very
unfortunate that when that happens so I
hope I really hope that you know he'll
be able to get to that rating sooner
rather than later and then just focus on
his GM title and the players here are
not just competing for norms we also
have fabulous prizes you know we always
take care of the players here in st.
Louis for our Grand Master norm group
nine thousand dollar prize fund total
and the champion walks away with $2,000
in our International Master norm event
six thousand dollars on the line our
champion leaves with twelve hundred
dollars okay well we are wrapping things
up here on our kickoff show remember
tonight at 5:00 p.m. at us chest champs
calm it's round number one of the 2019
st. Louis norm Congress Alex
any final thoughts before we see the
games tonight all
I mean I'm looking forward to watching
these games I'll make sure to tune in
and see the games live today so that I
get a sense to see who's started off
well and more to talk about tomorrow but
in general what I wanted to share with
everybody is how important it is if
you're really trying to get those norms
it's very important to most importantly
psychologically being in the right
mindset because I remember the first
time that I got my norm
I was really tested like there was tons
of times during that tournament where I
was offered draws early in the game or
even before the game by GM's and I
declined them all and then you know it's
basically the game of chess rewarded me
because in that tournament I was getting
lucky breaks and it's like I felt like I
needed to take advantage of every single
chance I had in that tournament because
later I started struggling in the second
half of the tournament but I felt like I
needed every single one of my points to
really get the norm whereas if I even
once or twice took draws at some point
in good positions then I might have you
know the game of chess might have kind
of turned his back on me and I might
have not gotten the norm and I know I've
half I don't want to mention names but I
have friends who have struggled with a
psychological part of it I mean they
came very very close to becoming GM's
but they just were often missing by a
half point or one point because
psychologically they couldn't quite
believe in at the wrong moment they
didn't quite play for a win when they
shoot or something like that and and
then they just couldn't quite make it so
it's very important to be
psychologically in the right mindset if
you want to become a GM or and I am for
that matter because if you don't believe
then you know nothing else will it will
be hard to compensate for that if you
know what I mean exactly well we have a
lot in store for you the next few days
the next five days as a matter of fact
remember us chess champs calm tonight at
5 p.m. you can see round 1 games and you
were talking about our group be filled
with Rochelle Wu the bottom seed taking
on the top seed Olivier chika rata
that should be interesting and much more
the next time you will see Alex and I
will be tomorrow at 2 p.m. Central time
will be in the midst of round number 2
and will bring you the best of that
round and much much more so for the
world's greatest production B team Danny
Machuca the T the technical director
Isaac Krantz is graphics and audio Eric
Mosel is show designer he's grand master
Alexander Linderman my name is Ben Simon
until tomorrow we say so long from the
Show Me State
[Music]
you
you